reconnaissez-vous ce jeune homme blond
avec des lunettes noires
sûrement pas si vous n'êtes pas un fan
de la saga harry potter
young mitchell de son vrai nom alias
colleen krivets est un jeune apprenti
sorcier fans d'harry potter et qui ne
cesse de le prendre en photo
ce jour-là à versailles les rôles sont
inversés
la magie a opéré les fans moldus ont pu
rencontrer trois acteurs de la série
une occasion unique voire magique
d'échanger avec eux souvenirs et photos
on est vraiment tout seul avec le
traducteur et l'acteur on a deux petites
minutes pour vraiment on peut lui poser
une petite question ou deux et on estime
notre photographe donc c'est quand même
un moment de partage et c'est vraiment
bien la voir en vrai c'est encore
différent que les voir à l'écran puis
discuté un petit peu avec eux voir
comment ils sont plus dans la vraie vie
entre guillemets et oui fallait voir et
avoir un petit souvenir de quoi
organisée par la boutique spécialisée
versaillaise l'armoire geek ce week-end
rencontre a attiré plus de 2000
personnes pour le plaisir également des
acteurs j'adore participer à ce genre de
rencontre voir les fans de voir à quel
point ils sont passionnés
j'ai vraiment de la chance de vivre là
il pouvoir faire c'est la première fois
que je viens à versailles donc c'est
vraiment sympa c'est marrant de
rencontrer les fans je ne l'avais jamais
fait avant je n'avais pas encore eu
l'opportunité de le faire sur le sida
une nouvelle rencontre est déjà prévue
l'an prochain entre fans et acteur à
versailles selon nos informations deux
journalistes moldus celle ci devrait
avoir lieu en février
harry potter c'est ainsi grotte